one of the things we saw in 2020 was
that it's actually unsustainable to live
that way you actually need a like a
final truth to add a vertical Dimension
to your existence and the need for that
is why people knelt so readily for the
BLM people right was they needed
something to kneel before or like for
instance the fouchy of it all right I
represent the science he's obviously not
talking there as a scientist but he is
fulfilling a very deep need and that is
for clerical Authority so the
proposition in the book is look You're
Gonna Worship something actually there's
gonna be a Bedrock um so why would you
get these puttses like fauci to serve in
that role why wouldn't you seek a you
know a deeper and a more ancient and
have more tried and trusted version of
that kind of
I'm Dave Rubin and joining me today is
the host of The Young Heretics podcast
and author of the new book I've got it
right here in my hand how to save the
West ancient wisdom for five modern
crises Spencer Clavin welcome back to
the Reuben report Dave it's a pleasure
to be here thanks for having me
Spencer I believe this is your first
solo time on the Reuben report you've
been a panel guest but as a as a
published author with the hardcover book
and might I say on the back with the
blurbs you really killed it one of the
names on this list is just spectacular
this uh Megan Megan Kelly just wonder oh
Dave rubin's on there too that's very
nice uh there he is I didn't think
anybody respectable would want to be
associated with me and so that's why I
reached out to you no
yeah I do what I can to to help the
sales uh I am glad to have you on solo
uh truth be told we are also friends
outside of the uh these little internet
boxes and we often talk about basically
uh what your book is about and it and it
really is about what so many of the
things that I do on a daily basis on
this show are about so that will set us
up for this thing so first off for the
people that just uh maybe haven't seen
you on the show aren't familiar with you
uh give me a little of the background
that leads you to writing a book like
this because you've got quite a pedigree
that this does make sense for you to
write oh sure well I as you know you
know I went to all the fancy schools
which is kind of the like Top Line
reason why I know about the you know the
great texts of the Ancients but I think
you know somebody who comes out of the
universities these days especially in
America has a lot of explaining to do
because the the schools are just falling
apart and I I think that you know
basically what I wanted to suggest to
people in this book and throughout my
whole career is that you look at the
news cycle and every day it seems like
there's some new crisis that is is
flashing across the headline something
else is going wrong they're transing the
kids all of a sudden the economy is
falling apart the you know the internet
seems to be destroying everything and
like America is breaking apart and what
I wanted to propose and this is based on
a lifelong love of the classics and of
the great texts of the West is that even
though every day seems to bring kind of
something new to fret about a lot of the
questions that are underlying our
problems are questions that have been
asked again and again in fact they go
back to the origins really of uh human
thought and some of the answers that
come down to us from Antiquity are
better and saner than the stuff you get
out of your modern gurus so even as the
academy is kind of going insane and even
as I was traveling through the academy
and and seeing some of that Madness
um at the same time I was really
confirmed in my conviction that these
great books which sort of sit on the
shelves they look kind of Dusty and
intimidating they're actually for you
they're about how to be good at being
human and this is these are you know
points of wisdom that we particularly
need now as the digital era kind of
rockets into uh it's it's new phase so
effectively what I'm doing in this book
is I'm just you know inviting people to
consider the fact that these aren't
actually new problems they're taking new
forms
um but the there are uh precedence for
them there's a way to go back into the
past and talk sanely about them not just
for cookie College professors with blue
hair not just for nerds like me who go
to fancy schools but for everybody and
especially for people that care about
this country and uh want to save it
Spencer if I'm understanding you you're
telling me that there is knowledge that
people before us knew and that there are
things and ways of analyzing reality
that luminaries such as I don't know
CNN's Don Lemon or msnbc's Joy Reid
perhaps don't have a great ability to
tell us about
I mean I thought they were all so smart
I thought the whole point is that people
of the modern day are so smart and
everyone before us was a bunch of racist
backwards homophobes and misogynist
don't forget about that so yeah I mean
I'm definitely like you know every
possible slur you could throw at me
um I I accept them all if what that
means is just that I don't think wisdom
or information was invented in 1965. I
mean in the book I call this
chronological chauvinism right the idea
that like newer is better and basically
every answer about man's place in the
universe was discovered post-scientific
Revolution
um yeah you go those guys you mentioned
the Don Le Mans of the world you know
the Nancy Pelosi's of the world Edward
saeeds of the world they'll they'll
sneer at you for suggesting that
actually it's not inherently evil to
talk about things like Western culture
and they laugh as if this is like a
ludicrous suggestion but why shouldn't
it be the case that people people who
have thought deeply about these things
over time and throughout the the history
of our Traditions have arrived at some
pretty good answers I think we're
cheating ourselves out of those answers
if we ignore or we just cast off
everything that went before us to some
kind of like racist chauvinist holdover
right and it's weird because at least at
a mainstream level that seems to be what
people are doing at every given moment
we just wake up you you see what's going
on in the world and you have some really
sort of half-witted ding bats I'm not as
learned as you are so those are my words
uh who are who are analyzing this stuff
but I thought a nice way of doing of
doing this interview would be you
basically are laying out you've sort of
uh already uh laid out what the five
sort of topics of the book are the five
crises that we're dealing with but we
could just kind of go through spend a
few minutes on each one actually so the
first one that you talk about uh is the
crisis of reality and this this is sort
of connected to our inability to
actually say what is true and that
people have their truth not the truth
and that this has also gotten
complicated because of the machines and
Ai and all that yeah well I mean it's
funny when 2016 happened and bad orange
man was elected to the presidency you
suddenly had this new concern about
post-truth politics that all of a sudden
like you know the the Trump is saying
things that aren't strictly true and
like he has hype men who spin for him
and all of these things and you know
even I am old enough to remember that
like the arguments over whether what the
meaning of is is go back to before
Donald Trump right I mean you had when
that was around 96 I vaguely recall yes
I think that was uh you know and and
then you've you've got stuff like you
know the the memos on Bush the Killian
members on Bush were fake but accurate
that was in New York Times a headline
about you know these these sort of
falsified charges against Bush that Dan
Rather raised and once you start to look
at this you realize this is not like a
bad orange man problem this is a much
much deeper problem and I think it goes
back to a question that was actually
raised right at the very beginning of
Western philosophy and that's like you
said it's what is true is there such a
thing as true and false
um people think that they can just
answer that question in the negative and
sound sophisticated like oh yeah there's
nothing either good or bad but thinking
makes it so
um and my argument is that there's no
halfway version of that proposition if
you if you take that pill you got to go
all the way and what that means is the
only thing there is is power which is
what you're seeing now right people will
just insist that you call them by the
pronouns that they have invented because
they're reality their truth is what
they're going to enforce using the state
if they can if they can get their hands
on it um so that's the first section of
the book is about kind of the ancient
answer to that important question which
is yes some things are true or false
whether you wish them away whether you
digitize them away or not and if you
don't want to live in a world of pure
power politics you've got to get on
board that train the reality train so
what could we do now because so much of
what you know I do a daily show every
day and I I constantly I do a daily show
every day it's quite remarkable and uh
every day of doing a daily show that is
true by the way it's been every day yeah
absolutely true but what can we do I
mean I'm always talking about how we're
having this sort of breakdown in reality
because if you watch certain things what
is true in your world is very different
than perhaps what is true in my world I
don't sit here telling you that I own
the truth but but how do we sort of
Arbitrage those two uh those two ideas
that you know this is this and that is
that we're going to start living in very
different places sure enough I mean I
would say that the question I
continually encourage people to ask
themselves and others throughout the
book is how's that working out for you
and I think like the in the abstract you
can sit in a philosophy seminar and say
well my truth is just as good as your
truth or you need to accept my truth
um but in in point of fact when you
start to do that you notice all these
ways that it breaks down it broke down
uh in stalinist Russia you know when the
the professors started arguing that
there was no real need for evidence to
convict somebody because we just know
like according to spiritually according
to the party that he's that he's guilty
um and and you you see all the
disastrous consequences of this stuff in
the here and now and the more we can
bring each other back to the here and
now the more we can engage in like face
to face I mean I know here we are on on
a digital like Communication System but
you mentioned at the outset like we have
a real in-person friendship we share
ideas with one another
um and and people are really craving
that they've been told that they like
don't need it or the zoom is fine
lockdown is good for you actually you'll
know nothing you live in the Pod
whatever
um we know that that doesn't work so the
thing I insist on is like a constant
face-to-face encounter with one another
especially in our communities that's why
the stuff that's going on in like the
school boards is so exciting because
that's where people actually have to
like face up to the consequences of
their uh of their beliefs and of their
actions and the more we insist on that I
think the the closer we get back to
reality
all right so if we slowly but surely get
back to reality that would be a nice
concept uh that would sort of get us to
the second part of this because uh you
talk about the crisis of the body right
and right now we seem to be in this
situation where many people's reality of
their physical reality seemingly is not
matching up with their mental model or
their mental reality and the rest of us
are constantly talking about this trans
issue despite the fact that it's it's
very small percentage-wise it seems to
have leaked into like every part of
society
that's right and you make a really I
think that's a great point that we kind
of fixate on it even if we aren't
feeling it ourselves and that's kind of
a key I think to a lot of this because
when this kind of stuff comes up of
course it's really easy just to get into
like a kind of conservative fist
pounding mode of like those bad deviants
right there doing the bad stuff and one
of the things I try to point out in the
book is you know this is a definitely a
dangerous and and uh destructive kind of
ideology the notion that you can like
pump children full of hormones is
obviously I think evil and and wrong but
we have in order to understand it if we
if we really want to kind of get over it
or move past it um we have to understand
that it's a response to a very very
ancient and deep problem which is the
problem of the body the problem of the
flesh which like you know you can find
people from the early days of Greek
philosophy wrestling with this in the
book I talk about a neoplate philosopher
called platinus whose biographer from
Antiquity says he seemed ashamed of of
being in his body and I think that the
reason these two things are connected is
because when you start talking about
reality about absolute truth you very
quickly start to talk about ideals right
like Beauty things that are the way they
are regardless of you know whoever just
disagrees uh you know absolute truth
kind of lives in this pure Eternal
sphere and we don't live in that sphere
we live in a really messy kind of world
where people break down and die and like
you know you you get you get man colds
and all sorts of stuff all sorts of bad
stuff happens and and when you face up
against that you start to want to kind
of crawl out of your flesh and I think
that the trans ideology the transgender
stuff kind of plays on that sort of
offers to people this vision of
themselves that doesn't depend on you
know living In the Flesh on like seeking
health and goodness in the here and now
but promises some kind of other worldly
future you can uh zoom up into and you
start to see that this develops very
quickly out of transgenderism and into
transhumanism into like a whole new kind
of uh you're going to evaporate into
like some digital space you're going to
come become an Android or whatever
um once again in the book I just insist
on asking like how is that working out
for us you know it's it's a proposition
that's based on something that's
currently making us sick and and
miserable and the proposition is like
just maximize it just go to Infinity
um so I present in the book kind of an
other way basically of looking at this
that yes there's more to us than flesh
but the things that we seek are actually
found through the flesh that our bodies
are kind of language a language for our
soul
um and I think again this is like a much
healthier and saner way to engage with
yourself and with the rest of the world
um but it does require that you actually
like face up to the consequences of your
your actions which again requires coming
back to that reality and actually like
looking at yourself and those around you
uh and and making a sober assessment
you know it's interesting because we
could spend all day long talking about
the the trans part of this uh but I
think actually maybe for a moment we
could spend on the transhuman part of
this this is the idea that people will
replace body parts with robotic body
parts and you know digital IDs in your
hand and if your eye uh eyesight's not
working you could potentially get you
know some sort of robotic eye the Litany
of things artificial wombs outside of
the body there's so many things here and
it's for me I'm sort of two-minded on
this because on one hand there's this
sci-fi part of me that I I grew every
every movie that you if you went through
my favorite hundred movies or most
watched movies 99 of them are probably
sci-fi so I have a great Affinity to all
of this stuff and the imagination of all
of it and then there's this other part
where it's like man look what in 20
years the internet has done to all of us
did it make us more social more happy
more connected or did it actually do the
reverse and I would now fear that while
it might be cool at some level to have a
super strong arm like Will Smith had an
iRobot we might be trading on something
that we would regret which actually
isn't that far off from the original
trans conversation you know you replace
some parts but there still might be a
problem there it's sort of like he got
promised RoboCop but they actually
turned you into the Borg do you know
what I mean like there's like yes yeah
that's the that's what you're describing
I feel it too because I really don't
want to become one of these guys that's
just saying like all this Tech is bad we
gotta reverse it we gotta run through it
that's always the danger and I talk
about this a little bit in the opening
of the book just because it's very easy
to slip into and to be accused of like
wanting to turn back the tide of History
some of this stuff is gonna come into
existence
um there's no real version of the future
I don't think where it doesn't start to
we don't start to do things that you
know for instance like we're already
seeing these implants that can fix or
help with blindness with uh heartbeat
people being hard of hearing and we can
recognize that there's something good in
that at the same time as like you say
there's also this philosophy behind it
that's kind of what I'm trying to get at
here this driving idea that not only is
it good to restore our faculties or
enhance our faculties it's actually good
to just transcend what we are all
together and I think that's why the Borg
is such a powerful image and Star Trek
actually is because that's about
dissolving the boundaries of yourself
um and the the philosophy that I resort
to in the book to deal with this stuff
which is called hylomorphism is a fancy
word for form in matter that you kind of
you never really get beyond having a
human body you can you can you know use
that human body in different ways
um I I think that that's the key to like
deciding between the Robocop and the
Borg of it is like is this something
that kind of uh takes what we are which
is a soul in a body and enhances it and
uh you know brings it brings us closer
uh in some way to the the meaning of
what we are or is it something that
alienates us from ourselves and
ultimately kind of makes us disgusted
with with our flesh is the other part of
this where it's not even going to
necessarily do that much to your
physical body but you will have follow
Mark Zuckerberg who I'm fairly certain
is a synthetic Android into the
metaverse meaning that you won't have to
actually you know the transhuman part of
this is that you're literally going to
replace body parts replace eyeballs
things of that nature but the other
version of this is the purely digital
version of this which would be more in
line with like the Matrix where we will
still exist like this but we will be the
battery for the Existence in the digital
world where you can be an ogre or a
furry or whatever else better O'Rourke
is doing at night yep
uh well Beto I'm sure is already you
know those guys already have the more
advanced technology we don't even privy
to so I don't want to think about like
what's going on in that in that sphere
but like no I mean this is this is the
flip side of it and rather than like
fixing your body or changing your body
the kind of offer here is well what if
you can just engineer your brain so that
you feel things that are totally
unrelated to what's actually going on in
your right so literally in real life you
could be a 350 pound five foot six you
know guy and in this Digital Universe
you could be the hottest chick ever or
vice versa or whatever
exactly yeah that's uh like there there
are Black Mirror episodes about this and
that you mentioned the Matrix and
actually I think that sci-fi is a really
interesting key here to thinking about
this stuff because there's really no
sci-fi version of this technology where
it's just totally a good thing and these
are always kind of presented in
dystopian form it's really easy to tell
this story about a dystopia
um it's really hard to tell a story
about this that that goes well
um and one of the things I argue
throughout the book is that art you know
is is kind of our in in let our inroad
to the intuitions that we have kind of
seated even deeper than what we can
really consciously articulate and so
there's something important about the
fact that all of these sci-fi stories
are dystopian stories and I think it's
that you know whenever you pull back the
camera whenever you tell that third
person story there's always somebody
manipulating the virtual reality
technology that's why those press photos
of Zuck walking down the aisle with all
those guys his head said strapped to
their faces that's why those were so
damaging to him is because they kind of
reveal the the third person objective
view of what's really going on
um and I I think we shouldn't let
ourselves be talked out of that
intuition that we have that we Express
in our in our sci-fi we all we ought to
listen to the wachowskis because they
were on to something right well it's
just like man we we all know this will
lead us to something close to dystopia
maybe we're in it already and we don't
even know that fully but yet we seem to
be following the people who screwed up
so much in the first place Zuckerberg
for example but but let's move from that
to to the crisis of meaning because
obviously those things are connected as
well there seems to be at least in a
modern sense amongst young people
uh a complete crisis a meaning really
just like a sense of like what's the
point of this whole freaking thing yep
yeah that's right
um I think this kind of boils down to
you know you can see it in in our art
and you can see it in our science at the
same time this kind of idea that like
we're really just throwing stuff at a
wall you know the the primordial soup is
like generating all these different
options and some of them kind of endure
and survive and some of them don't
um and I I think that this is you know
where you get to where the rubber kind
of meets the road on that relativism
question that this stuff doesn't work
when you chase it all the way down and
there's a simple reason why it's like
when we make art when we make memes when
we build civilizations when we interact
with one another
um we take it for granted that there is
some Bedrock to reality some kind of
final good or ultimate existence that
you know everything else is kind of
referring back to that and unless you
have that then there's no like real
meaning to your statements at all you
know we can never really look directly
on this you know this final truth but
we're always trying to approximate to it
we're always trying to represent it
express it in all these different ways
um and the thesis of the Like Richard
dawkins's of the world is basically like
that's just an illusion like all there
is is just this kind of you know endless
repetition and you know different
variations and and I think like one of
the things we saw in 2020 was that it's
actually unsustainable to live that way
you actually need uh like a final truth
to add a vertical Dimension to your
existence and the need for that is why
people melt so readily for the BLM
people right was they needed something
to kneel before or like for instance the
faucy of it all right I represent the
science he's obviously not talking there
as a scientist but he is fulfilling a
very deep need and that is for clerical
off Authority so the proposition in the
book is look You're Gonna Worship
something actually there's gonna be a
Bedrock um so why would you get these
putzes like fauci to serve in that role
why wouldn't you seek a you know a
deeper and a more ancient and a more
tried and trusted version of that kind
of thought you know it's interesting
because one of the things that I think
helped my own Spiritual Awakening
obviously not only being on tour with
Jordan Peterson and being around that
and that sort of thing but you know
during covet one of the things that I
noticed really quickly was that people
who were Believers whether they were
Christians or Jews whatever they might
be even if it was somewhat amorphous but
they they considered themselves a
believer in something they seem to not
go as crazy as the pure secularists
because the secularists I think were
doing the Dawkins move that you're
talking about there it was just like you
could wake up on any given day they gave
you a set of information here's the data
here's how many people are dying here's
what's going on here's why you have to
stay in your house and then you just
respond to the secular lunacy every
single day and I I saw that was in stark
contrast to people who because they
believed in something else maybe it was
a various set of things
they believed in something else they
didn't necessarily have to believe in
the immediacy of the day wow and that
kept them sane throughout that that's a
great observation this is this is a
point on which the sage uh Bob Dylan and
the novelist fyodor Dostoevsky are are
in agreement there's there's a line in
one of Bob Dylan's songs you've got to
serve somebody might as well be God
right you know and this is kind of your
to your point that you're always serving
somebody the only question is whether
you know you are or or not and those
folks that believed in something that
you were observing kind of knew that
they were doing that and so they were
able to like remain even if a leap of
faith you know even if believing in a
higher power is I won't say it's
irrational but it is it is a rational in
the sense that you can't make a logical
argument for or against that's
conclusive you make the final proof now
I know for certain that there's God I
can't disbelieve in it
um but even so putting that block in
place at the beginning of your
philosophy then makes everything else
that you believe saner and and more
rational whereas if you don't put it put
it there you get this kind of just yeah
like you were saying the day-to-day
everything kind of churns everything's
different you know today whatever the
experts say um but this is the plot to
bring it back to Dostoevsky this is the
plot of Brothers karamazov in a certain
way that he's got this guy Al yosha who
is really just an intense kind of
spiritual Mystic like he you know he
kneels and prays in these very kind of
you would call them almost primitive
ways and yet he's way saner than
everybody else around him who's kind of
supposedly the scientific rationalist
everybody goes insane throughout the
novel except Pharrell yosha and I think
that's kind of what you see you know on
tour with with Peterson or you know
among the people who believe in
something it does actually keep you sane
in this really interesting way right and
then bizarrely we also saw the I would
say cult-like not necessarily religious
like but the cult-like worship of the
CDC and the NIH and quite literally
people hanging little uh little little
fouchies on their Christmas tree and all
of these things and in many ways it was
like yeah okay you guys did pick
something to believe in it just ain't
the right thing look I mean we're having
this conversation how many days after
the Grammys where Sam Smith dressed up
as Satan and that was it CBS from their
official Twitter account that was like
yes we're ready to worship like this
stuff gets so explicit you know and it's
and and you it kind of is presented in
this ironic tone but actually it's it's
it's more it's saying the quiet part out
loud like it's it's more true this is I
don't want to like get ahead of
ourselves here but this is kind of the
crisis of religion section of yeah so
all right so before we jump well that's
the next one that's that's number four
here but before we get to that you know
on the Sam Smith Point I think this is
sort of also what you're saying I kept
thinking look I I'm for art and I don't
have to like everyone's art and I accept
it to be and by the way you know I'm a
child of the 80s so you know there were
major you know hard rock bands mega
death and you know Marilyn Manson and
all doing all eating bat heads
a lot of it was before my you know you
know me I'm I like Frank Sinatra but the
point is the point is I can accept art
that I don't like or whatever but but
the art has to be good and what I
thought with the Sam Smith thing was
well this was just shock drivel the the
music is not good it's not saying
something it's not giving you something
if you had given me good music and then
just done all of the most disgusting
things around it you could probably
separate some of those pieces but but if
the art itself is not fundamentally
beautiful or good
then then I think you have a bigger
problem that seems to be where we're at
now the shock value was only for shock
value not because it was trying to
actually say something
um yeah or it's like the transgression
is the point or something right right
there's nothing and it's like what is
that what's the purpose of that right
well I mean I think this is something we
are like recovering as a society again
sort of against our will like Kicking
and Screaming we're coming to realize
that there actually is a moral Dimension
to Art like there's no escaping the fact
that art depicts the world but it
doesn't depict the world just like the
way that say math tries to or sometimes
like objective history will try to just
say these are the facts
um that's not the way we experience the
world we experience the world as you
know things people do have moral
Dimensions to them if you if you steal
the bread from a homeless guy that's an
evil act and if you portray that in in
art you can't fully portray it unless
you portray it as evil like unless you
kind of associate it with its
consequences and it's spiritual
Dimension and so you know we think of
the culture wars as this fight between
like conservatives who want morals in
art they want to like tell you not to
say certain things or whatever and then
the Liberals just want everything goes
right you kind of this libertynism or
whatever but that's really not the fight
we're in anymore I mean Sam Smith by
putting those devil horns on is actually
making a moral claim and it's what
you're saying it's that the
transgression is somehow valuable that
like this is what you should strive for
um and the ugliness therefore also
becomes part of the point like it's in
service of that performance that there's
really nothing of value or virtue in it
otherwise it kind of sucks that the song
is like kind of overplayed and also
right well it was just like well give me
something here give me something here so
that it is not just what it obviously is
and I I don't sense that there was
anything else there but all right so
we're already sort of into the the
crisis of religion here so uh the Sam
Smith need God
I think Sam Smith has a God I think he's
picked one I mean I genuinely I think
like this is kind of we've been we've
been talking around this a little bit
now that like there really is no such
thing as atheism
um this is something that the the Bible
has this great line the fool hath said
in his heart there is no God and people
kind of read that and think that that
means like the fool it's it's foolish to
be an atheist it's stupid to to believe
in in no God um but there's a deeper
level to it which is that the only a
fool can deceive himself into believing
that nothing serves the role of God in
his life that that there's nothing in
that place of highest good highest power
um and so I think you know this is what
you see when you see the kneelers at BLM
rallies when you see Sam Smith you know
like offering uh sacrifice on the altar
of kind of like ugliness and and illogic
um these are people who just worship
just as profoundly or as intensely as
you or I uh they just don't know that
they're doing it and that's kind of
where I mean the the Bible has lots of
passages about this that you know when
people start to worship idols they start
to forget that that's what they're doing
it's kind of it's a kind of self-deceit
um and I think all of this is just like
you know it's kind of unnecessary
because it's based on this false
assumption that in order to be smart in
order to be rational in order to be
scientific we have to we can't possibly
say that the thing we're worshiping is
actual God like is actual an object of
worship
um and that's kind of the crisis of of
religion which I talk about so if we
were if we're going on this theme here
that the West is worth saving and we're
trying to save the West uh I assume you
don't want to force all the people to be
Believers or force or all the people to
have the same religious beliefs that you
might have so how do you how do you
blend those two things a sort of uh what
you describe as a necessary belief for
this stuff to be saved but also the
ability to to have people and ideas on
the margins right I mean I think I I
think that forcing somebody into a
religion is kind of a contradiction in
terms and that's part of the illogic
that makes this that made this stuff so
distasteful when you force somebody to
convert at a point the point of a sword
you basically have created a false
belief it's just somebody saying
something to get out of getting killed
essentially
um and so not only is that inherently
bad but it doesn't solve the problem
which is that what you're really dealing
with is uh a void in people's hearts and
and so what I say in the book is like I
would look I would love it if everybody
tomorrow became the kind specific kind
of Christian that I am and went to my
church and said the Nicene Creed every
week and whatever I think that would be
good
um but I'm not here to like write a law
that says that I'm not here even to like
bang you over the head with with my
Bible I'm just here to say that actually
you already believe certain things that
imply this this higher power and and we
should fess up to that like just by
getting out of bed in the morning you
sort of concede that there's something
there's some reason to do things and
once you say there's a reason to do
things then you have to say there is a
highest reason some good toward which
all those goods aim
um and I say in the book it's less a
conversion than a surrender we we ought
to you know be not be ashamed of being
honest about the fact that mankind has a
spiritual Dimension and we can look
directly at that without feeling like
we're you know primitive or
superstitious or or what have you it's
it's actually the other thing that makes
us primitive denying that there's a
spiritual realm is what turns us into
kind of primitive worshipers of fauci or
or BLM or whatever
you've given me a fine segue to the
fifth here which is crisis of regime
because we seem to have a bunch of
people that worship a regime that has
very little to do with their interests
in mind uh that that kind of sums up to
me where we're at politically at the
moment and I don't mean just us from an
American perspective I think kind of all
over the world at the moment that's
right that's right I mean I talk in this
section of the book about the classical
theory of regimes and about what a
republic is supposed to be because
that's what we're supposed to be is is a
republic and part of the point of a
republic is that you uh Rule and are
ruled in turn as Aristotle says nobody
is born you know with with spurs on his
uh on his boots and nobody is Born to Be
subjugated
um we have a kind of shared distribution
of power that that it doesn't flatten
everybody out into sameness but does
give people you know ownership each
person has ownership sovereignty over
his own choices and yeah you're seeing a
lot of people that like don't want that
or uh are falling for the kind of
removal of that
um and what I identify in the book is
kind of the the problem here is the
breakdown of what the Ancients would
have called philia that's friendship
just Civic friendship just the love
between fellow citizens
um you know we haven't heard heard the
State of the Union Address yet but I'll
be willing to bet that Biden when he
does get a set half a sentence out of
his mouth and is able to form a word
he's going to say something about those
nasty evil ultramaga crazy bad people I
mean this is a guy who at one point said
that like we had a pandemic of the
unvaccinated so congratulations Dave
you're a disease I mean like that's
really like where this happens
indeed just just like a virus would be
no but I mean like this is this this is
the the kind of talk that unmix
republics that kind of it's like acid
that you just pour and they divide us
out they say like oh you're you're gay
and the straight people are inherently
oppressive you're black and the white
people hate you and you're a woman and
the men are bad and and and this is
really where as a you know as a
political matter civic association
neighborliness small community like the
kind of stuff actually that you're
seeing over in Florida right the the
this kind of real federalism that then
leads to a kind of national movement
back against the the tribalism and the
just Bonkers sort of leftism
um that's where this becomes not just a
kind of philosophical imperative but
actually the only political possibility
for us to to turn this thing around
right it seems really really obvious to
me at this point you know having I just
saw you a couple days ago in Florida and
having lived here now and everyone knows
my feelings on Florida so I don't
belabor that but it's like I live in a
world both physically and I would say
philosophically that makes sense to me
that I think are good that are obviously
in line with a lot of things you've
written here and then if I was to take
someone like someone I talk about on the
show often say Joy read on MSNBC she has
the polar opposite ideas she thinks that
Florida is evil she believes in
neo-racism and obsessing over skin color
and gender and sexuality and all these
things I don't know other than a other
than a disassociation and moving to our
own communities and geographically
separating I don't know how you put
those two things together so I guess the
founders were really onto something with
this federalism stuff I know those nasty
evil chauvinist whatever backwards white
slave folders I know right so I mean
this is Madison's uh argument in
Federalist 10 that the true and because
because it's not a guarantee by the way
that you can do republicanism on such a
bit in such a big country I mean that's
kind of the problem that the founders
were up against uh and and this was the
solution that they proposed and I think
in our times it has a specific value
which is I think people like you and me
outnumber people like Joy Reid when you
get us away from the honking screaming
idiots on on MSNBC like I actually think
that when you do what DeSantis is doing
and you state boldly like making no
bones about it Americans are Americans
you know you're you're not going to
teach kids about like 57 genders
um because that's wrong and that's not
what we do in America
um what did he find in 2022 right that
was like the most successful approach to
those midterms and it was successful
across the races right it was an
interracially successful proposition
um and you can find that sort of thing
when you create these you might even
call them safe spaces right like safe
havens for same people who want to live
in reality
um and and that can lead to National
change but it has to start locally like
you're saying
Spencer Clavin the book is how to save
the West we will link to it right down
below and we will break bread in the
great state of Florida soon enough or
you're in Tennessee that's pretty good
too we're free here as well yeah come
have some hot chicken
we'll see you there see you soon my
friend likewise thanks my friend if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of mindless dribble check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell